[Music]
such an such an amazing film I have a
lot of questions for you um to start I
would love to hear about the the the
screenwriting process and the two of you
how you started on this what was the
what was the original idea when you
started talking about doing this was it
were you approaching was the idea from
the start a courtroom drama or was it
about a marriage or what was the sort of
seed that got this
going I think it's complicated sometimes
to remember exactly the you know uh
because sometimes for me it's like when
you have two two lines you know who
cross and you have the idea when the two
lines are crossing so qu and um but I
remember I think the marriage was the
main thing you know to dive in that Co
in that uh cople that story and um but
the idea when I when I we had the idea I
think it was when we said okay maybe I
we don't want to take the hand to The
Spectator and say okay come on come
inside this this house to to see to
watch how they live but to go through
the courtroom through the trial
to um to understand that story you know
she's not speaking it's always the other
who who are uh speaking instead of her
so she's yes in a way she's dispossessed
of the and I think it was the the the
main things you know to say to say okay
it will be a portrait yes but a
portrait uh sorry that will go through
this process in order to discover what
happened could you talk a little bit
more about and Arthur as well about how
you how you literally how you write
together were you sitting together
talking it out did you did you come up
with an outline first was there what was
the process of developing this as two
writers together I think there is two
two time the first time is just you know
just sit like like like us to just
discuss and not don't we we didn't write
anything but um the first of all it was
very funny just just desire you know
okay the song will be very
we maybe we'll tease something during
one hour you know and after a recording
song will be will appear in the in the
courtroom and just desires and after
it's okay we have to build the you know
the thing so after it's much more
complicated and when the dialogues uh
starts we we just separate uh us and in
different rooms and we're just sending
email we are just sending emails
emailing each other in the same house
yeah exactly all the time and say okay
and I don't know if it's uh correcting
but just yes doing a lot of Correction
on scene on scene on scene and sometimes
we we were not always uh agree about
everything so sometimes we we're like no
it's not this it's not that but but yes
I think it was very now the only thing
it's because we are living together so
there is we have no time you know when
you're when you're working with a with a
script with a screenwriter screenwriter
sorry um you you have time you know and
with arur it was sometimes it was at 2
a.m. or you know okay I have an IDE and
okay and so it was funny and of course
because arur is a director in uh first
of all uh the work was of course to WR
but in to to have
sorry switch
in but also there was not just the
writing there was also planning the
direction and since Arthur is always a
director there was lots of uh of
building up on these Direction ideas
together um Justine since you mentioned
you you you said we didn't have time I
want to go to that scene where Samuel's
saying you know he wants his time back
that that scene is so incredible it's
one of most powerful sequences in the
film to me and I loved watching it um I
mean one of the pleasures of this film
to me is the well the language these are
people who know how to talk they know
how to argue they don't give up they
they keep going both of them and
obviously in the court as well you have
a similar Dynamic of people who know how
those both those lawyers even though I
despised one of them are so good at
their jobs but that scene where the same
saying I want I want my time back and
she's just unrelenting and saying you
know you have you have so much self-pity
that entire could could you talk a bit
about that I mean I have a lot of
questions about that scene but first the
writing of it yeah I think it was very
very complicated to write because we
first of all I remember that I always
said to Arthur
I I don't like these people I don't want
to to you know this it's the only scene
that we have it's the only piece of real
of truth of them so we had to to give
something to the audience who are which
is not just uh you know the the cliche
of the of the fight scene so I think we
discussed a lot of the base of the base
of the beginning of the how how it
starts you know after of course it's
uh there is a lot of things sexual
problem jeal jealousy many things but
the base was very important and when we
we had the idea I think of of the the
the the the you steal my time you know
it's so it's so Universal you know every
people could have that kind of feeling
in their life to say Okay I I lost my
time with this man and with this woman
he steal me something he stole me
something you know and I think when we
had the this idea said okay this is
except for very rich people because they
have some uh you know solutions to
to to help us uh to help them but uh I
think a lot of people could have this
kind of frustration you know and when we
have that this base after it was um
quite easy I think uh
no but maybe you want to add
something um no the the yeah the this
the scene had to be consistent and we we
we knew long before starting to write it
actually like the dialogues we we knew
we had
to
to yeah it couldn't be just a good scene
it had to be strong and
really powerful so it it it
of course when we found the topic of
time then it was more natural to to to
know how they would speak and how they
would think and especially how how the
man would would think because he's he
he's a character that we're like from
the beginning we hear about him but we
don't see him we hear his music we
everybody's talking about him we see his
face we see photographs but we don't
actually know who he is so it's the only
scene in which he he's his humanity is
is like really existing so we had to
find a way
in how could he talk how could he
Express himself MH so yeah it was a lot
of a lot of layers of writing for yeah
and we we were obsessed by okay we need
to have
a they still love each other a little
you know it was very important to keep
this in that scene but after you know we
were so lucky to have some and Samuel
because they of course they embodies
they embody you know the and everything
is going
up yeah they really raised the level of
of of the acting of the human
interaction with such good actors yeah
in incredible yeah I mean one thing I
love about that scene is it's it's so
ordinary it's so mundane it's a couple
having an argument about time and right
just I've had that argument and uh but
the stakes are incredibly high at the
same time um obviously when you see
where it ends up but even before the end
it's like the way they play it and it's
so fully lived in that moment it's just
like it's
completely because I think that you know
sometimes when people in that situation
could be just ugly you know ah we are an
and it's just impulses things
but like there it's it's a battle of
ideas and and the only thing who change
everything is when he's talking about
the child and say okay your child thinks
that about you and it switch something
in her in her mind and say okay and
after that she's she's really really
terrible with with him but I think what
she's saying to him is true you know is
real when she said okay okay you're not
a victim you're not you know and I think
this point
was she's not
just how
sorry she's not a monster when she said
that she actually say what she
thinks everybody find a way to justify
themsel but mhm
um Justine could you talk about the when
you were in production I'd also love to
hear you talk about how you shot that
scene um were you doing long takes where
they were just running the entire thing
um because and you're you're pretty it's
like medium shots to closeup so I'm just
curious what what was the set like and
how did how did you for that yeah yeah
uh it was special for that because I was
very afraid about the this shooting day
and uh all you know sometimes it's with
the sex SC but there is no sex in in
this movie but uh there is always one or
two scenes in the movie that you are so
afraid you know you are like ah I have
to I have to to overcome this this
moment and and this scene was really
really yes of course for everyone and uh
we prepare we had two cameras and
because uh it was just long shot and on
one on on Samu one on SRA and I think
yes it was a 15 minutes shot uh around
and uh it was physical for everyone and
U and Sandra asked me that she said
please uh let me really uh come inside
the the level the you know the and yes
she was very high uh since the first the
first no just not high in the yeah yeah
she was high in Emotion
yes no she was sober of course but she
was high in the way and uh and no she
was very it was complicated because at
the beginning it was pasta bolog pasta
and she said please not bolog please
because I will be red you know in so we
changed as we switch it was just with I
think I no don't remember it was yes
white pasta pasta with with vegetables
yeah but uh but she she ate so much so
many pasta you know and it's very
special because in at the at certain
moment it was really complicated for her
to because there was a lot of takes and
a lot of pasta because uh so because you
yes and so yes she was she was
unbelievable because you know she she
was really uh involved in that scene
like um very few actors she was
uh yes and you know she was obsessed by
the violence when the violence is coming
you know and when um and we made a lot
of of of versions and I prepare
something uh right now for the DVD and
uh we we we choose to to have all the
takes you know and I so I I I saw again
all the text and she was totally crazy
she was in the very very strange mood
you know and uh between the Tes she was
she was she keep she kept the the the
the the the the energy so she was like
okay it's okay like yes maybe you can
just add some funny and said no and uh
it was yes it was it was crazy of course
but you know
we
what I love with great actors like
Sandra is that they just transform the
lines and you no longer know that they
were your lines they they sort of
possess it uh in a in a new way
mhm I mean she is so remarkable in every
scene in the film can you talk about
when did she get involved and you how
did you come to
Caster or or was she in mind when you
when when you were
writing it was it was one of the
starting point we were writing for son
yeah yeah yeah we I was obsessed by her
since Cil because she has she had a
small part in my previous movie but she
was so involved so so generous and and
yes I think there is a the Paradox with
SRA because you
know in in in the in life she's so
transparent she's so you know she's so
true she's she's without any kind of
sophistication you know and I asked to
her to play that that part which is um
usually played by woman you know very
mysterious we with a you know a lot of
uh yeah it's a cliche you know in in
swers to see women like this you know
I'm doing something but I'm thinking
other the things you know and I think
SRA is playing this with a kind of uh a
sort of uh very she's not seducing
anybody you know she's really really
she's okay it's my life I'm not I'm not
um self
critic yeah she doesn't feel she has to
justify herself and she doesn't use
artifice yeah so so I think she's
uh she's playing it like with a very
contemporary way of doing you you know
what I mean I think she's uh yes so she
was very modern in the way and so it was
very interesting for me and of course
because I like to do a lot of text we we
we we have done a lot of course on set
it was it was very interesting because I
I love so much when I
uh take the the space to uh to spread
out you know to to to take to take the
space to and for me the the the set is
really the place where we can uh try
everything and and not close you know
everything to say okay I think I'm the
opposite of the director who say just
okay baby do this and go no I I need to
to explore something on set because for
me um
yes I need when actors I I love so much
when actors drop everything you know all
the defense all the yes the defense or
all
the yes all the sophistication things
all the artifice and the makeup was a
great uh we had a great discussion on
makeup because at the beginning I have I
had some cliche in my mind I said okay
maybe on in the courtroom you can be you
could be much
more uh MCH made up sorry and and I
think it was a cliche in a way because
you know in um witness for persecution
in the Billy wer movie that I like so
much Mal is like you know the the the
the perfect woman uh really uh who is
the placest in a way you know and uh and
SRA brings bring me something totally
different say okay okay no we are we are
playing different card a card of okay
I'm like this
[Music]
umum yeah I own who I am yeah and uh I
don't apologize for every for anything
you know so she bring me this I think
incredibly yeah um I have to ask about
music okay you have the you have the
music queue of the year with 50 Cent PM
I mean the steel version it's absolutely
incredible what were you thinking how
did that come to you was that in the
writing process like were you guys
writing with that in the background or
um no it was not in the writing process
because it was Jolene it was Jolene of
Delon we wrote with
Jolene we even had the like the the the
lyrics were a part of of one scene in
which the the the bad lawyer is uh
trying to explain why he intentionally
put this music because because the the
lyrics are directly speaking to Son but
we didn't have no but but I had this
tracks no this this track this track in
my computer since three years three
years ago it I think it was one of my
favorite you know maybe I I heard it I
don't know 300 time lot of time I I love
so much this version but it was my music
it was not for the movie and after when
when Jolie doly Bon said know we were
okay we have just uh two weeks to
find the the music and I was totally
very very uh anxious about this and I
say okay 15 cents is the best and uh and
uh but you
know yes and I think it was interesting
because there is this version is special
it's I like very much the original but
it was too expensive for me and I think
it would it would have been much more
you
know too much too much meaning you know
with the the lyrics and and uh this one
is particular it's it's weird you know
it's not too hype it's not too
parisan not hip Parisian like it's you
don't know exactly it's of course you
know this song because it's so famous
but it's not you know and uh
yes it yeah yeah yeah I'm sorry now I
just can't stop thinking about Dolly
Parton in this film sorry sorry sorry no
no for me I love so much Jolene and I
think it would have been very different
but I loved so much the argument in the
courtroom about the lyrics of Dolly Bon
so I was very disappointed because I was
like ah you know we we have to put all
in the garbage uh because of that uh
well I to me it's the funniest line of
the film when he the lawyer say talking
about the misogyny and then the other
training go it's
instrumental yes
yes we W it at the end just just before
the S you just to
line um but I also would love to hear
you talk about the other music and the
music is very spare in the film I mean
aside from PM you have it's when the sun
is playing
the you have the the scenes when the sun
is playing are so significant Cho like
how you chose when when to include that
um and then there were there were also a
couple moments where you
have music playing over scene where it's
not actually happening like it
um there's two moments and now I'm
forgetting with the child on on piano oh
no on other things well at the at the
end there's when you over like really
you hear you hear the you hear
PM when it's not happening in the in the
actual scene it's it's carrying over
from the previous scene I think no no
not p is always in the film is always
actually it's always in yeah the only
one is at the end okay it's one at the
end that's but but you know the the
music for the it's interesting because
you know in the writing process at the
beginning my producers told me okay what
do you want for the music you want to to
to meet a compos
composer composer and I said no I I
don't want a composer because swers and
and all the movie like this the genro
movies always with music like this with
huge nap no not nap it puts you to sleep
mhm yeah no it's not that no no it's not
that oh it's it's overwhelm design you
know uh it overwhelms the movie yeah
it's like you know it's much it's very
classical you know you you put on
Netflix and everything you know I am
okay you have you have the the the same
things you know all the time so when we
decided to to do that movie I said okay
we have to be very radical in a way on
music and to find something to not do
the same thing that everyone do expect
yeah yeah and uh and we decided okay
maybe the music will be just done by the
by the kids by the by the child sorry
and we could see the evolution of of uh
you know the time with the yeah with the
just the piano so we decided of course
for the credits at the beginning to just
see he's really not able to play the the
albanis track track and uh and just yes
you can you can see the evolution but I
think yes of course when you are doing I
think a movie like this you you can't
you cannot say okay uh you you you come
inside a genre so you have to be very I
think uh
[Music]
yes you have to find a way to break away
from the expected and find your own way
and the music for me was really uh one
of of the no and yeah yeah I remember
okay so he AET jet sleeping was
interesting to to
to F when we were writing to find where
the this this it was like a a
secondary plot like is he going to be
able to make to to to to play this this
difficult piece yeah it
had a little Fable side of that like a
fable it was like uh this this young kid
he he
has strong things to face and and at the
same time he's trying to to achieve
something on his own which is playing
this part so it was like a parallel uh a
subplot yeah yeah subplot with the music
it was interesting to think of it that
way yeah I I felt like every time you
went to him or often times it it felt
like it was coming out of some intense
scene with the two of them and then it's
this moment of rest with him but it's
not just rest because you're seeing what
you were just saying it's like he well
how he's progressing or not with piano
but also what's going on with him and
what's playing on his face and I'd love
to hear you talk about how you found him
I I don't know if you've worked with him
before he's incredible I mean thank you
uh it was a huge casting really really
long because we started with with just
um Blind and Visually Impaired child you
know so I wanted really really a real
vigilan blind child and it was really
really complicated because in Europe you
know we we we were in different
countries for this and uh and uh I think
uh we didn't we didn't find find him and
after we open to all the childrens but
we discovered that the lines was so
difficult for everyone you know it was
really really hard and I think we were
looking for a child to
uh writing level was a little too high
for the age of the child we were looking
for medic difficult and so when we when
we met Milo it was very crazy I think
he's a little nerd you know in real in
real life and I was like okay he a he's
not speaking like other children's you
know and uh and yes it was a very it was
so beautiful the way because the way we
discover him was with the sound I not
choose him with the with the picture you
know I just saw the picture and said no
it's not the child of
SRA so I just put it and just we were in
the same place with Arthur and at the
moment he said oh you know it was the
evening we we just it was always the
same thing I put all the casting and we
just hear the children's and at the
moment he said wow who is the children
he's not speaking like and I said no no
he's not looking like s it's not
possible and after he go back for the he
did a go a call back and he was so
amazing he was
totally a level of intensity it was
crazy crazy and uh I at the end I asked
why why did you C like this why how how
you and just said my brother is a is an
actor and I'm very
jealous and I wanted to have that cast
because my brother has everything and
not me and I was like okay it's good
it's a motivation for this was crazy he
was really really amazing you know it
was just an exercise with with the key
and just we
are the coach at the key and said just
ask me the key and in in your Castle
there is your favorite animal and you
want to save your animal you know it's
really all the The Childrens were not
good in that ex and him is like give me
the key give me the key and it was in
the in the in really me I'm not in a
good act with sorry but it he was it was
really really amazing wow wow and after
I say okay he could do is he not just a
nerd he could have you know something
else so and after yes he was he has no
cell phone you know it's he's he's he's
not like over kids you know yeah I mean
I love the I love the scene in the
courtroom when I me I love he right he
has he's got fragility and
I worry for him like throughout the film
and then he's the one who's in a
position of real weakness as as the
child and the fact that he delivers the
testimony in court where then you see
the prosecuting attorney just knows he's
he's lost it's such a great moment it
was the boy the kid brought him down it
was beautiful beautiful yeah I think it
was one of of the most difficult scene
to shoot because I think he changed he
changed at that moment he he grow up
really at that moment he changed he yes
it was it was very interesting and for
me of course because I'm a director and
it's not the same work when we are you
are working with actors amazing actors
and when you work with childr you have
to be you you have to be different it's
child so I had to be of course so
um
uh I had to be so
careful thank you sorry
and
yes yeah but for me I like so much to do
that job for this too because you know
there is a kind of of um yes it's the
first time you know I saw the first time
the for this that kid in a movie you
know like this it's so amazing of course
because uh he loved that so much so it
was amazing to see that kids to it was
amazing yes and of course with animals
too it's always uh full of surprise oh
yeah I mean that dog is amazing yeah
yeah the dog yes yes yes it was a lot of
work but not my work the work of Laura
Martin the the the train trainer who
works a lot before because uh to obtain
that kind of things you have to prepare
a lot months few months before if you
just ask for a huge structure with
animals uh just for the you know one
week before you you don't you cannot do
these
things um I wanted to ask going I guess
this is going back a writing question
did you know from the beginning had had
you both made the decision that the film
was going to end the way it did where um
we see the outcome of the trial but
that's it you don't you don't learn what
you know really happened or you don't
learn it's left to the audience to
decide what they think happened was that
in place from the beginning yeah because
you know I think yes very very yes
because uh you know we it I hesitated to
to adapt uh a real story you know and um
I think as a spectator the case that I
adore is are always the case when you
don't know at the
end uh not always but most of the time
and I think yes for me it was very
important the the question of the of the
doubt
doubts are really really Central uh in
the movie and I think it was
yes yes because you know the scene when
Marsh told to the child okay you have to
decide now you have to decide it was
really important in the movie to place
that child in that position and I think
it's um yes the
story talks about an emancipation an
emancipation of this child and I think
of course it going through this uh
doubts doubts yeah I'm I'm curious if in
the process of developing the film and
then making it did did anyone ever push
back on that or push you to give a
different ending to reveal more like
producers or financiers or everybody was
on board no but we had a lot a lot of
different uh ends yeah we thought of
different endings well always with doubt
but lot of was no no ending in which in
which we like learned at the very end
what really happened something but it
was all all the end the end the ending
that we thought of were all about the
mother and the child andh what's going
to happen after uh after the end which
is not an end because everything is
still too to be lived but all the very
good stories I think it's always you
don't know it's like Aman nox staircase
there is a lot of of stories like this
always is you don't know OJ no OJ
Simpson we know but
that we do now no but you know when when
when there is a another things you know
there is a the first things or Simpson
is very interesting because of course
the
first it's it's one of the most
interesting trial in the world I think
because there is a first story and of
course of course the case is talking
about a much more important
thing in America but I think of course
it's
um I like when when the first
sorry I like when the first scene of a
movie is appear to be very
ordinary I think and then it evolves in
something way more complex you know that
kind of movie it could have been just
okay we don't you don't know who is she
okay we you will go two hours to
understand who she is but no it's the
opposite you don't know who she she
is um time after time you say okay oh
wow it's much more complicated that that
why I S before you know and it's of
course it's a c it's
human
the more we dive into the story The more
we realize how complex it is and the
more we cannot contain them in a very
few lines of story MH and I think even
she didn't kill them maybe she pushed
him to committed suicide maybe she you
know maybe she's she could feel guilty
now because she of course she was
violent of course maybe he was violent
but you know there's a lot of doors who
are opening in the movie after the even
of course the H don't it Stills
important in the movie yeah but by the
way something you just said reminded me
of the moment when in court when she
says she's being questioned about the
fight and what what is the slap and she
says he was slapping his face and that's
such an incredible moment and I mean I
just felt it was in that moment she was
absolutely telling the truth I think
that is in that Mo that's yeah right
that is that's what happened in that in
that moment and it's just but it was
nothing I as a viewer would have
expected and um anyway um but you know I
to what you were just saying like you're
playing with genre and and the Thriller
the film works as a thriller like as I'm
watching it I'm captivated I I'm leaning
in like wanting to know what happened
like what's going to be revealed and
there's that inherent tension and
dramatic energy to it but by the
end I actually don't know what happened
and I don't care I don't care and I but
it doesn't diminish the experience of
watching the film for me because it
works on this whole other level where
it's it has nothing to do with the
thriller or the genre it has to do with
them as humans and everything that
you're exploring about just people being
unknowable to each other and to
themselves and and all of it I mean so
it's fascinating that but it still works
as a thriller I mean as a as a kind of
class
courtroom trial because you know as a
spectator I saw a lot of Cal movies I
saw everything maybe sometimes very not
good movies some sometimes
Masterpiece um like
Anatomy of a Murder sorry uh and and uh
I think what I adore is when um we you
overcome the question of just uh the
well-crafted
the things you know the the good twist
at the end you know I'm very AF I I'm
afraid about the twist you know
sometimes twist could be really really
disappointed for everyone you know ah
okay you you you bring my hand to to
that this end you know but it could be
like this for with our with my movie but
um we had we had a huge discussion about
about the you know the sound the sound
the recording recording sound sry
because at the beginning it was just a
sound in the the courtroom and not
seeing anything and after I say okay
it's too clever it's too against the The
Spectator if you don't show something
about the this maybe it's too you know
not clever you
know yeah it would have film on on on a
too high above the the the audience not
generous not giving him give give them
this but I think when you leave this
scene after having um seen that scene
sorry it's a jet now my English is
really uh um I think you say okay I
understand in what kind of movie in what
kind of uh what kind of of movie I'm
watching because you say okay it's not
really
uh you know it's
it's yeah thing
[Music]
after I think putting the the film uh
the fight scene in the movie I I believe
that the spectator then understand that
this is not just a thriller or a court
movie it's also the human aspect that is
very interesting and they get on board
with
that
yeah um so I I think time for one more
question and I I did want to ask you
about the Chalet a couple questions did
were you fil was that your base were you
actually filming at that Chalet or the
interior shot there or was that honest
yes yes so you were like based there for
a while was that that was kind of yeah
it was a nightmare because there was
there was no snow so it was awful we had
to you had to create it all yeah it is
not not ecologic at all so no no it was
it was really complicated of course
because uh you know the climatic yeah
the warming the warming of a planet yeah
right a problem um well I feel like that
house that Chalet is such a key
character in the film and the way the
interior spaces feel and and the way
they
the characters are relating to each
other in there it's it's I mean it's
it's a gorgeous space but it's it also
just tells so much about them and the
and and the world and of course we you
even it's not a huge reference for for
us shining but because of course shining
is a is um the base of shining just the
idea of a whiter it's the the woman here
but uh who's coming in the place
uh with calm and all the the time to to
create you know and of course it's a
trap but uh the idea of the Trap of a of
a beautiful place to to create uh with
all the time that they need and uh
and and it turns into a nightmare
everything yeah yeah and everything goes
against against there it turns into a
nightmare in fact yeah yeah
yeah she's typing Sandra must be a good
girl or what yeah
yes wow well um thank you so much for
being here thank you for coming and
doing having this conversation thank you
very much thank you all for
[Music]
coming